Hello Freak bitches.
Did you see the Philadelphia conference that I,
that I sent you,
which is about,
uh,
about what people's guilt.
I'm guilty.
What did they do?
There was a,
I was white.
There was a white privilege conference.
I love that article because weighted this side,
I'm sure.
Yeah.
Yeah,
you did.
I was like,
why is my Twitter blowing up?
Oh,
Joe retweeted me.
Uh,
so there was this white privilege conference,
which was a kind of politically correct talk fest,
right?
Eh,
and it basically ended up consuming itself entirely because the people who were
attending it decided that the conference itself had become too white.
So they went,
they will get it.
They were all there.
So they had this Hashtag um,
white privilege conference.
So what WPC,
so white,
uh,
and it started after one of the speakers there who was a white historian,
went over time and won an Asian American,
attend a,
a woman tweeted out,
great keynote,
but going over time a lot.
It is another example of white supremacy,
Hashtag white privileged conference so wise.
And he also made them
stake of using the n word in his speech.
I mean he obviously was using it in a historical context cause he was talking
about race in America.
But once that happened,
uh,
I mean what could possibly go wrong using the n word at a conference about white
guilt,
right?
Then everyone starts tweeting inward.
Never acceptable from Hashtag white folks lips deeply offensive and traumatizing
hashtag white privilege conference.
So white and that was from a white
tweeter.
So then it's like a snake eating its fucking tail.
Right?
All these white people just accusing one another of being too white.
You're all white.
We get it,
we get it.
It's would Michael Shermer calls virtue signaling.
Right,
right.
It's there.
They're letting the good,
it's perfect for a term there.
They're trying to find someone who's made some sort of an error and they're
attacking them with full force.
Yup.
And it's also like they're ignoring context on purpose.
It's like by saying that the word is,
it's never acceptable to say the n word.
By saying that and putting that in a tweet,
that's not true.
It's just not true.
Like,
if there's a reason to say it,
if you were explaining something that happened,
what someone said,
how they said it,
you are allowed to repeat the word.
The idea that you're not allowed to repeat the word around grown adults is to
pretend that word is magic.
Yeah.
So pretend that word's going to conjure demon.
Well,
it also empowers the word I.
In fact,
I feel stupid for even having used the phrase,
the end would cause ordinarily I just say nigger,
if I'm talking about the existence of that was shot the podcast on,
Hey,
I'm Australian so I don't understand context.
Right.
But I mean I was talking about this a,
I'm on my podcast about,
I do think that we,
we've gotten away from like where is the other person's heart and what is their
intention?
Yeah,
there's,
there is,
um,
let's see,
you could think of it like an Amoeba around your physical body,
cloud
of,
um,
pulsating thought forms.
And,
uh,
as you're imagining,
you know,
a,
the beautiful elements of life and things,
it's,
it seems to be in a kind of order and uh,
and maybe kind of wafting upward it,
these are like,
uh,
the,
the spiritual positive,
uh,
kind of frameworks sometimes that you're seeing life through when you're
tripping,
you know,
and seeing the connections between things,
lines forming and things like that.
The,
the more kind of organic geometries that that show up,
you see this intelligence of life and the,
uh,
the,
the light of divine intelligence that came through for Allison,
like in this language,
it,
it's seems to be weaving things together and when you're in touch with that
infinite light that seems to be the source,
uh,
then that is it.
You can keep it upwardly moving and very evolutionarily caught cosmically
consciously moving forward.
And when then you're thinking regretful thoughts or thinking negative thoughts
and anger and things like that.
There's a constriction that goes on in your heart I think,
and kind of shuts things down in that kind of like you were saying,
twisting in,
curling in and darkening and,
and things are,
are all,
uh,
things that when you're journeying,
you see them manifest literally and you're the flow of your,
the theater of your imagination.
And so I think you really beautifully described that.
Uh,
just in that I was totally there.
I think it's a disease of consciousness.
I think it's very similar to catching a cold that,
you know,
uh,
you don't see the cold,
you don't see a disease,
you don't see it,
but it affects you.
And I think there's an analogy to be made about diseases of consciousness that
you can get locked into these terrible ways of looking at the world.
I found for a while I enjoyed living within very strict guidelines.
It was just easier when we go to a restaurant because I used to joke that I
would like to be buried and a bread basket with a fuck ton of butter,
like bread and butter is my thing.
Um,
and when we go to a restaurant and they bring the bread,
like I just,
I don't even touch it.
It's not mine.
I just,
it was so,
it was nice to not even have to think about all these things.
Um,
but then,
I don't know,
I,
a few months ago I just thought,
I don't feel like this is really doing anything for me anymore.
And I miss my lean cuisine dinners,
which is what I used to eat.
[inaudible] cuisine.
They're not bad.
Yes,
I know all the things you can miss.
I know.
Well,
healthy choice dinners as well.
What the fuck you doing with that process?
Bullshit.
I know I had stopped eating the process of which I missed.
I missed the bullshit I missed.
I missed the wood pulp wood.
What is Wood Paul?
It's probably some kind of filler in there.
I'm just saying there's like wood pulp in your food in Parmesan cheese,
I think.
Why didn't that come out recently?
What?
Right?
Yeah.
Jamie knows Jamie,
what are you talking about?
What?
What kind of Parmesan cheese and just the,
the,
you know the bottle of Kraft parmesan cheese.
It came out that a certain percentage of it is like wood shavings or something.
Hearts.
Jesus Christ.
Why are they putting wood in your cheese so that there's a,
it's day just plants though.
That's right.
Cheese.
You sprinkle co what?
Cellulose.
Okay.
Hotly contested.
But perhaps now for reasons,
right?
Think FDA investigation found that a Pennsylvania company,
castle cheese incorporated had doctored it's so-called Parmesan with it.
Mix of cheap cheddar cheese and cellulose.
Also known as wood pulp.
Oh,
well if you say cellulose,
that doesn't sound right.
Yeah.
Cellulose just sounds like like fiber from plants.
Plant material.
Yeah.
Hmm.
Well there shouldn't be plant material and fucking cheese.
You can't,
assholes should go to jail for that.
Putting fucking wooden cheese.
You can't just do that and you can't mix cheddar cheese with wood and call it
Parmesan.
So attached should have its own new variety name,
wood,
pulp,
cheesy thing,
right.
Just call it that.
Yeah.
People would buy it.
My mouth is watering.
Well,
you're eating lean cuisine and saying,
I don't know what it is in the processed frozen dinners that I like,
but that's what I like.
Sort of like when I smoked,
I was like,
yeah,
I think it's the fiberglass in the cigarettes that I like.
Yeah.